the
[Music]
what if I told you a single clove of
garlic could multiply into a small
fortune if you do it right by saving
your own seed year after year you can
compound your profits and turn just a
small handful of cloves into a thriving
profitable small farm Enterprise garlic
is one of my favorite crops to grow it's
easy in some ways you plant it in the
fall Harvest it the next summer and
there's little maintenance in between
but to grow a successful profitable crop
you need to follow a few key strategies
from planting dates to KN when to
harvest I've faced pests diseases and
even total failures but over time I've
developed a system that works and in
this video I'll show you how to
sterilize your seed stock prepare the
soil fertilize plant protect Harvest
cure and save your own seed so you can
grow garlic that thrives year after year
if you're new here I'm Chef Mikey I'm a
former executive chef turned Urban
Farmer and garlic is the crop that truly
inspired me to start growing my own food
after more than 20 years in the
restaurant industry I was used to seeing
garlic come in tubs already peeled and
not very exciting but then I discovered
a variety called music at my local
farmers market it's a hard neck garlic
that originated in Italy and made its
way to Canada in the 1980s thanks to a
garlic Enthusiast named Al music known
for its love large easy to peel cloves
and incredible flavor it's no surprise
it's become a favorite amongst Market
Farmers it's my absolute favorite crop
to grow when I first started growing
garlic I assumed it would take about 8
months from planting a clove to pulling
up a perfect head but I quickly realize
it's not about the amount of time it's
about the right conditions in my climate
no matter whether I plant in October
December or even January it's usually
ready by early to mid June and more
Northern climates it can indeed take 8
months or longer but here planting too
early caused my garlic to grow too fast
and the tops get damaged by winter now I
wait until about December 20th and I've
been seeing much better results now
spacing and fertility turned out to be
just as critical garlic is a heavy
feeder and overcrowding can really stunt
its growth even after I fixed my
planting date spacing and fertility
regimen then I found some of my bulbs
rotting in the ground a test from my
local Extension Office revealed garlic
bloat nematodes probably introduced
through contaminated seed now I
sterilize my seed and save my own seed
stock year after year I also manage
common pests like alium Leaf Miners and
onion maggots with insect netting by
experimenting with interplanting flower
and crops to attract Predator insects it
took years of trial and error but I
finally fig figured out a system that
reliably produces healthy Market ready
garlic now let's dive into exactly how I
plant fertilize and protect my garlic so
you can avoid my mistakes and grow your
best crop yet I actually grow my garlic
on a least property rather than in my
backyard it takes up a lot of space and
stays in the ground for a long time so
it just didn't makees sense to use my
most valuable real estate at home the
plot I'm using this year was basically a
blank slate about a year ago I started
by tarping the entire area until late
February which helped kill off any of
the weeds and gave me a clean start
after pulling off the tarps I planted a
cover crop mix of peas oats and mustard
that cover crop fed the soil and once
terminated acted as a sheet mulch to
suppress future weeds we built beds
right on top of that Mulch and planted
winter squash there for the summer then
after harvesting the squash in September
I tarped the plot again to keep it weed
free until garlic planting time in early
December I pulled back the tarps and
Broad forked the beds to help with
drainage my soil is heavy clay that can
get really compacted after loosening it
up I added a solid six in of fresh
compost on top and laid down wood chips
in the walkways this created a nutrient
Rich weed-free environment that's
perfect for planting garlic to prep my
seed garlic I started by gently breaking
each bulb into individual cloves keeping
the skins on if I can but don't worry if
a few cloves lose their skins I've never
seen any negative effects from planting
them that way next I soak the garlic in
cheap vodka for about 20 minutes the
Vodka helps kill off garlic bloat
nematodes bulb mites and any other
pathogens that might be lingering on the
cloves and it usually meets organic
standards although I use organic
practices I'm not formally certified so
cheap vodka works just fine for me after
the soak I strain the garlic and spread
the cloves on my greens drying rack to
let the alcohol evaporate meanwhile I
make a compost tea by steeping a pouch
of compost in a 5 gallon bucket of rain
water then adding a couple cups of fish
Emulsion I also mixed in a fair amount
of micro risal inoculant called MOG gasm
that my friend Heber makes I've had
great results with it on my tomatoes and
I'm excited to see how it benefit fits
my garlic finally I place the dried
cloves into these old Olive containers
that restaurants give me for free I pour
the compost tea until they're fully
submerged I snap on the lids and I let
the cloves soak while I drive out to my
least property about 30 minutes away by
the time I arried they've been in the
solution for roughly an hour then I just
pour off the liquid before planting we
prepped the beds a few days earlier so
everything was ready when we arrived
with our pre-soaked clothes each bed is
30 in wide and 50 feet long with 18inch
walkways we use 100ft tape measure to
easily measure each 50ft bed just
stretch it down the center and mark off
three rows at 6-in spacing we place the
cloves on top of the compost in their
spots making sure each one is root end
down and pointy side up we're planting
into about 6 in of compost ensuring that
each cloves root end touches the native
soil below over time the compost will
settled so we bury them just deep enough
to allow for that without risking rot in
the clay or making the Harvest too hard
once everything's lined up we simply
pushed each clove in with our fingers or
a small digging tool then moving on to
the next row in my Tennessee climate I
don't do much after planting I don't
bother irrigating or adding extra mulch
our Winters are relatively mild and
straw or hay can introduce weed seeds we
also get enough rain in the winter in
Spring that I don't need to set up
irrigation I usually see garlic shoots
poking through around February from
there maintenance is minimal a wire
weeder once or twice in the spring helps
keep weeds in check and the Deep compost
mulch does the rest as the weather warms
watch out for pests like onion maggots
and Alum Leaf miners which can devastate
a crop in early April you can cover the
garlic beds with insect netting so the
adult flies can't lay eggs on your
plants complete exclusion is the best
prevention organic sprays like spinosad
can also work but it's less work to just
cover it once then spray multiple times
and let's face it nobody wants garlic
that's been sprayed about 4 weeks before
Harvest you'll see a curled choot
emerging from the center of each garlic
plant that's the scape basically the
garlic flour if left alone it produces
seeds though it can take years of
replanting to get a full bulb that that
way removing the Scapes can increase
your bulb size by up to 25% because it
sends the plant's energy back down to
the bulb plus the Scapes are edible and
can be a tasty and profitable early
season crop after removing the Scapes
watch the bottom leaves when the lowest
three to five leaves have turn brown and
the rest are still healthy it's time to
harvest waiting until all the leaves die
can degrade the bulbs and hurt their
storage potential weather can also push
your time timing if heavy rain is coming
and I'm close to harvest I'd rather pull
them early than risk rot or pest issues
to harvest I simply pull each ball by
the stem because I plant in a deep
compost mulch rather than heavy soil
they come up easily then we trim the
tops down to about 6 to 10 in just pile
them in crates and then we take them
back to the home base for drying and
curing we just leave the trim tops in
the field for now since we won't be
planting anything else here until fall
drying and curing is the most critical
step after all those months of work you
don't want your garlic to spoil in
storage properly cured garlic can last
up to a year but if you do it wrong
you'll lose a lot of your Harvest early
on I tried drying my garlic Outdoors
undercover for a couple of weeks but
Tennessee's heat and humidity in June
are a perfect recipe for mold it's also
tempting to rinse off your bolt and
reveal that pretty purple striping but
washing can ruin their ability to store
instead I just brush off any loose dirt
by hand leaving as much of the papery
skin intact as possible also keep 6 to
10 in of stem on each bulb so it can dry
and help protect the bulb from pathogens
entering since I don't have space to
hang my garlic in bunches I use a 4x8
grow tent equipped with a ventilation
system air filter and a dehumidifier I
spread the bulbs in a single layer on
wire shelving the dehumidifier pulls out
the moisture while the ventilation
system brings in fresh air and filters
out the strong garlic Aroma from the
house I check on them periodically over
the next two weeks to make sure they
don't show any signs of mold or rot once
the Skins turn papery I trim the roots
and the stems a bit more peel off the
outermost layer and store the bulbs in
mesh bags for long-term storage I keep
them in my office which stays around 70°
and 50% humidity ideally you'd want 60°
and 60% humidity but that's hard to
maintain in most homes right now I only
sell a small amount of garlic each year
because I'm building up my own seed
stock my goal is to offer certified seed
garlic in the future and I'm probably a
year or two from hitting that milestone
in the meantime I hope you'll stick
around and follow along and good luck
with your own garlic Harvest